en
este corte de cinta no solo inaugura un
edificio sino que marca una conquista en
cuanto a la lucha por disminuir la
discriminación por orientación sexual en
ciudad de méxico ya que desde ahora las
personas trans podrán recibir atenciones
de salud en un espacio creado
exclusivamente para ellos es un espacio
que vamos construyendo entre todos con
pluralidad con respeto garantizando
derechos y además de estos dos estas dos
unidades son punta de lanza para que la
perspectiva de derechos la visión de
inclusión la perspectiva de
universalidad y gratuidad vayan
avanzando en nuestra ciudad la
importancia pues es para empezar la
inclusión y que vamos a tener un
tratamiento de reemplazo hormonal con
médicos profesionalizados pero en la
jornada no todo fue celebración luego de
cinco años la fiscalía reconoció su
responsabilidad institucional y pidió
una disculpa pública a la familia de
paola o el rostro una joven trans
asesinada del año 2016
la fiscalía general de justicia de la
ciudad de mexico por mi conducto
reconoce la responsabilidad
institucional en las violaciones a los
derechos humanos referidas y ofrezco una
disculpa pública a la memoria de paola
buenrostro ya su familia y aunque
américa latina sigue dando pasos hacia
la consolidación de los derechos de las
personas trans de acuerdo con la ong
letra s y transciende pero méxico es el
segundo país más peligroso para esta
comunidad por detrás de brasil con 79
miembros de la comunidad lgbt asesinados
en el año 2020 43 de ellos personas
trans